[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
yeah we should go come on let's go oh I
actually I don't think I can I'm still
working on this anthro paper what all
she's gonna do my tomorrow
yeah same oh really I don't have any
free periods tomorrow God you never hang
out with us I really want to I'm just
I'm taking six classes this semester and
it's crazy I mean it's fun I'm learning
a lot but I'm so [ __ ] busy yeah well
your buddy should go yeah yeah oh you
got a fine um and write me to the next
one I'm down I hope so
[Music]
and so we should ask ourselves has
American political discourse really
changed at all feels like an a mmm dude
I'm so tired oh did you stay up all
night studying or something
I stayed up till 3:00 in the morning
reading about HH Holmes do you know him
no oh my god okay he's America's first
serial killer in like 1893 he built this
hotel in Chicago that he killed 200
people there Wow yeah he's to sell their
skeletons to medical schools crazy
anyway what did you do last night what
are you up to now probably to skip my
bio class take a nap
what did Jenna I love that class okay
you can use my notes okay one last thing
you guys use the big question do you
think Hamlet was faking his insanity Jim
what do you think okay okay Madison ah
no I don't think so I mean think about
everything he lost you can't believe in
religion anymore you can't trust society
he can't trust love and he can't even
trust his own philosophical beliefs
because all of a sudden ghosts exist and
I think that's plenty to drive a man in
very true but also you have to bear in
mind that his insanity only shows up
when he needs it to it could be very
calculating yeah I think about that guys
your essays are due on Wednesday if you
need me I have office hours later on
today okay no extensions this time okay
I mean it oh hey Madison hold up yeah oh
yeah I think you should read this book
on Hamlet I think it's gonna bring you
around from my perspective Oh awesome
take your time they don't heat it back
anytime soon okay great thanks so much
sure oh my gosh this class is an amazing
right so good I have such a crush and
professor watzmann he is so smart
what like a crush crush no like a
professor crush everyone has one did you
I don't really really what about mr.
Tomasson here he speaks six languages oh
uh no my cup of tea
really
[Music]
oh this I know I see these all the time
and it's getting away
yeah what's up hey I like just some
parties
yeah the huge I'd love to hang out if
you're around Oh
what you're not too busy with work no no
I finish all my work and I just want to
have like a fun weekend with you guys oh
my god you're gonna hang out yeah yeah
you wanna get drinks tonight
yeah yes awesome well we sure to the pub
and then I don't know whatever you guys
have
[Music]
Wow
[Music]